in the early days of computing
programmers needs to be very sure about
the data they were operating on if an
operation was fed a number when it was
expecting a letter a character at best
you might get a garbled response and at
worst you could break the system maybe
even physically now the low-level of
coding yeah that's still true but these
days we have programming languages where
we don't always need to be so rigorous
in defining the data and we can let the
computer figure it out but for something
that seems so technical
this can be controversial when you write
a computer program you use variables
which are basically just labeled buckets
of memory inside that bucket is some
data and you can change it you can vary
it hence variable I know it's a massive
simplification but computer memory is a
bit like an enormous rack of switches
storing ones and zeros that represent
other things like letters and numbers
but if we look into a region of memory
there is nothing in there to indicate
what those ones and zeros are actually
representing so in the code we declare
that the variable is a particular type
what's contained in that variable in
that bucket it's an integer what's in
that one it's a string of characters and
that tells the computer how to interpret
those ones and zeros in memory the types
that you get to use can differ a bit
between languages but in general you
will at least have integer or int that's
a whole number that can't have anything
after the decimal point and those are
extremely useful for storing things like
the number of times you've looped
through some code or how many points
your player has clocked up or how many
pennies there are in someone's account
then you've got character or char these
are letters numbers punctuation and
white spaces like the space between
words and instructions to start a new
line and in most high-level languages
you'll probably be using a string
instead which is just a string of
characters then you've got boolean or
ball named after George Boole an English
mathematician that's very simple it's
true or false a boolean only contains
either a 0 or a 1 a yes or a no no or
yes nothing more then there's floating
point numbers or floats floats are
complicated and messy in a whole other
video but in short they let you store
numbers with decimals although
you might lose a very small bit of
precision as you do it there are others
other types in a lot of languages I know
it's more complicated than this but this
is just the basics so most languages use
explicit type declaration so when you
declare a variable when you set up the
back bucket you have to also declare its
type so X is an integer it can only hold
integers and right now that integer is 2
but in some languages including some
popular ones that people tend to get
started with and that I like you don't
need to actually declare that it just
gets figured out from your code that's
called implicit declaration so in
JavaScript you can just type x equals
1.5 little no that's a number put the
1.5 in quotes it'll go it's a string
it's okay it's during 1.5 and 1.5 as
different ones and zeros why does that
matter well in JavaScript the plus sign
means two different things it's the
addition operator for adding two numbers
together but it's also the concatenation
operator for combining two strings
together so if X is 1.5 you ask for X
plus X it returns three but if either of
those X's is 1.5 a string it'll return
that and that's called typecasting
converting from one data type to another
sometimes some languages require the
programmer to explicitly request the
conversion in code other languages like
JavaScript there do it automatically
javascript is referred to as having weak
typing as opposed to strong typing in
its weak because even if that 1.5 is a
string and you ask for it x 2 it'll
return 3 unlike the plus sign that
asterisk can only mean multiply so it
can only handle an integer or a floating
point number give it a string that won't
throw an error like a strongly typed
language or it'll just convert it for
you on the fly really convenient really
easy to program with really easy to
accidentally screw things up and create
a bug that will take you hours to track
down or worse create a bug that you
don't even notice until much much later
in a lot of languages you can also cast
to and from boolean values which is
called truthiness and experienced
programmers who are watching this may
already be grimacing truthiness
is a great shorthand if you convert an
empty string to a boolean it
generally comes out as false anything
else true so you can just test for an
empty string with if X but that also
means that in JavaScript you can ask for
true plus true and it'll tell you that
the answer that is two because when you
cast true to a number you get one in PHP
a language notable for many questionable
design decisions even a string with just
a single zero in it will get converted
to a boolean false there's a special
case just for that string which can
cause a lot of unexpected bugs now there
is a workaround for that in loosely
typed languages normally if you want to
compare two variables you use two equal
signs like this you can't use a single
one because that's used for assigning
variables I have been coding for about
30 years and I still absent-mindedly
screw that up sometimes now if you ask
if 1.5 is equal to 1.5 with two equal
signs in JavaScript or PHP you'll get
true but if you had a third equal sign
then you are asking for strict equality
if the data types don't match any
comparison or automatically fail so why
is all this controversial well languages
like JavaScript and PHP
can get a bad reputation because they
use weak typing if you see yourself as a
real programmer and I am using that
sarcastically but if you see yourself as
the kind of programmer where you are in
control of everything then yeah you can
see that weak typing is like training
wheels it's something that introduces
sloppy coding practices and bugs and
shorthand and that's not unfair but weak
typing also makes programming easier to
learn and easier to do it can reduce
frustration and just make programmers
lives easier it is a trade-off even if
it is a controversial this series of the
basics is sponsored by - Lane the
password manager it's kind of obvious
that passwords are more secure the
longer they are but it can be difficult
to get the intuitive sense of just how
much more secure so let's say you've
signed up to - Lane and now you're able
to use long complicated symbol filled
passwords everywhere because - Lane
remembers synchronizes and auto fills
them for you how much more secure are
those passwords well let's do the maths
the characters that most websites tend
to accept for passwords are uppercase
and lowercase letters numbers and let's
say in 30 punctuation marks that's 92
characters there's an R
that you should be allowed to use any
unicode character in a password but it
is definitely an argument so let's limit
it to those 92 characters first because
we're using random characters we can
ignore word lists that make password
cracking orders of magnitude easier by
guessing dictionary words first
including like using an exclamation mark
instead of a 1 or deliberately swapping
a couple of letters those tricks don't
work here now let's say that an attacker
is able to test a billion possible
passwords every single second it's not
unreasonable if the encryption is weak
and their computer is fast if you have a
6 character password it will take them
at most about 10 minutes to try every
single possible one of these six hundred
and six billion combinations but every
letter you add multiplies that time by
92 seven characters works out to fifteen
and a half hours eight characters about
two months nine characters fourteen
years ten characters more than a
millennium eleven characters is a
hundred thousand years by the time
you've got to fifteen characters it's
about a thousand times longer than the
universe has existed long complicated
random passwords aren't a cure-all but
they're certainly better than the
alternative and to help you with them -
I am slash Tom Scott for a 30-day free
trial of dashlane premium which includes
unlimited password storage and sync plus
a load of other features and if you like
it you can use the code Tom Scott for
10% off
you